[Music]
there's something approaching from the
distance that you can't stop it can
completely destroy cities and kill tens
of thousands of people it mix like
another big wave at first but as it gets
closer you can see it's not just big
it's huge it's a tsunami you should
probably run away from it but instead
we're going to surf it seriously this
can't be good is surfing a tsunami even
possible and have people done this
before
well we better get started this is what
if and here's what would happen if you
went surfing on a tsunami the biggest
wave that someone has surfed on was
twenty four point four meters tall
tsunamis can be around this height but
for our purposes let's go a little
bigger and say ours is thirty meters
tall if you do want to surf on a tsunami
and we don't recommend you do it you'll
most likely have to travel to Japan or
the Philippines this is because they're
located in the Ring of Fire an area in
the Pacific Ocean where tsunamis are
most likely to occur but hold up how
does tsunamis occur anyway tsunamis are
different from the usual waves caused by
wind and tides tsunamis formed due to
volcanic activity but most often after
an earthquake occurs in the ocean if an
earthquake happens in the sea that's six
point five or higher on the Richter
scale you can expect a tsunami to come
heading for land this massive wave will
start deep in the ocean and build its
way up to the coastline quickly gaining
speed and power experts say that a
tsunami can move up to eight hundred
kilometers per hour as it reaches the
shore so be prepared if you can for a
wave as fast as a passenger jet
and although tsunamis start as small
bumps deep in the ocean as they reach
shallower water they become much more
massive so how would you surf on this
thing well let's hope you have a friend
that's just as daring as you because the
wave is moving so fast you'd need your
friend to drive up the wave on a jetski
while you hitch a ride on the back if
you manage to get to the top you'll
quickly realize that this wave is
completely different from any other wave
you surf before that's because tsunami
waves don't break as opposed to regular
waves created by wind a breaking wave
curves and cascades onto itself making
it the perfect wall for your surfboard
but generally speaking a tsunami doesn't
have this quality apart from the massive
size and the incredible speed of the
tsunami surfing on it would be nearly
impossible because there wouldn't be
much for your board to grip on to but
you're up here now so what do you do
well your best bet is to really hold on
for dear life and hope for the best
let's be real here
there's no way you're going to be able
to surf on this monster you'll quickly
be hurled towards whatever coast the
tsunami decides to bring you to and you
probably won't just land on the beach
either you could be several hundred
meters or even kilometers inland it
could hurl you against the side of a bus
or into a building and after the tsunami
brings you there that won't be all that
happens after it tosses you inland the
waves will pull you right back out into
the ocean now it's not only you in the
tsunami other people cars and even
entire parts of buildings will all be
forced into the ocean causing even more
destruction as they slosh through the
tsunamis path you may think it's over
now but that isn't the case a tsunami
isn't just one massive wave it's
multiple waves a tsunami can last for up
to an hour with waves up to 30 meters
continually hitting the coast while
destroying cities and killing people so
once you lose your surfboard you'd be in
the water with everything else being
pushed back and
or from the coast and back out to the
sea you'd keep doing this until you
eventually drown or die from getting hit
by debris so although surfing a tsunami
would make for a pretty gnarly story
maybe we should just stick to the
regular breakers for now one person who
might be a contender to tame a tsunami
would be legendary big-wave surfer Laird
Hamilton I got to admit I didn't know
much about big wave surfers until I
listened to his book life writer on
audible but he's one of the icons of the
sport and you get a real insight into
what goes on in the mind of someone
who's not afraid to tackle enormous
challenges audible is where so many
inspiring voices and compelling stories
open listeners up to new experiences and
ways of thinking listening makes us
smarter more connected people and it
makes us better partners parents and
leaders and there's no better place to
start listening than audible we're big
fans of audible here at under known and
we use many of their audiobooks to
inspire the videos that we make for you
so thanks audible for inspiring us you
can start listening today with a 30 day
audible trial your first audiobook plus
to audible originals are free visit
audible.com slash what if that's
audible.com slash what if to sign up or
text what if to 500 500 even if you were
to try and surf a tsunami and somehow
survived you would probably get pretty
badly hurt and be in a lot of pain but
what if you couldn't feel pain then you
could probably do it but we'll leave
that story for another what if
[Music]